these objects were produced by 3d
printers proof that for printing
technology the world is no longer flat
to make 3d printers this company
actually uses 3d printers a technician
starts by loading a reel of plastic
filament into a printer the printer
melts the plastic into a thick goo the
3d printer layers the plastic following
a pattern from a digital file this
particular part is the extruder body in
real time it takes about an hour to
print the extruder 40 different
components of this 3d printer are
produced using 3d printers at this
facility 135 printers run non-stop
producing gears brackets and mechanism
housings this technology is truly
self-replicating now a worker drills a
hole in the extruder body it serves as a
conduit for the plastic filament during
printing he bolts a gear to the extruder
body he screws the motor to the extruder
body and installs a second smaller gear
on the drive shaft
a part called the hot end is installed
next it contains a heater for melting
the plastic filament the worker attaches
the hot end to a 3d printed plastic
mount and extruder this completes the 3d
printer tool head another worker feeds
glass to rubber rollers the rollers
gently apply adhesive-backed polyester
film to the glass the glass will serve
as the printer bed and the film will
protect it from scratches during use to
build the printers aluminum frame the
worker secures the joints with 3d
printed plastic parts he installs two
rods horizontally they'll serve as rails
for the printer tool head to move across
he Clips the tool head to the rails then
he loops a rubber belt around the motor
on the side of the frame and links it to
the tool head the belt will drive the
tool head along the carriage next he
attaches the printbed and it's sliding
support structure to the base of the
frame he connects a cord to the power
supply and links it to the tool head it
will power both the motor and the hot
end he Clips the glass to the printbed
and tightens the clips with screws
in the testing department a technician
pushes the end of a plastic filament
reel into a drilled channel in the tool
head he snaps a retainer around the feed
point now he's ready to activate the 3d
printer for two-tone printing they use
two filament reels that feed into a
double extruder tool head the tool head
layers the plastic one color at a time
this process takes about an hour but
that's not too long when you consider
that it's printing a 3d object talk
about generating solid results